In the summer of 1976 the city of New York was thrown into a state of terror.
A mad man was on the loose,
wandering the streets and killing people at random.
This was a killer who loved publicity,
sending vicious torn zing Latins to the police and the media.
Each one was signed with the Monica son of Sam.
When feet finally caught up with the monster,
he was revealed to be a chubby introvert by the name of David Berkowitz.
In the biographics video.
Today,
we discover his story.
Okay.
The trials who would become the son of Sam was born or Richard David Falco.
On June the first 1953 his mother,
Betty Broder,
had been previously married to a man named Tony Falchi,
but when he left her for another woman,
she began a relationship with a married man.
Names Joseph Kleinman.
Bessie Antonio already had a child,
Rosslyn,
and when Kleinman found out that she was pregnant again,
he pressured her to give the baby up for adoption.
It appears that he also for to Betty from giving the child his name,
which is why she gave the trials how former husband's last name.
A few days after birth,
Richard was adopted by a middle aged couple names.
Nathan ends Peled Berkowitz who lived in New York,
says Bronx neighborhood.
The Berkowitz is owned a hardware store which occupied a large portion of
Nathan's time.
He was never close with his adopted son.
He be called David considering the adoption to be a mistake as David was her
only child.
Poe was extremely close to the boy though she indulged Davidson's let him get
away with things that need shouldn't have.
David developed into a difficult child.
He was hyperactive,
mischievous,
and ornery.
He was a bulky child since quickly learns that he could use his size to his
advantage and Lord it over other children.
He showed little interest in schooling and through a combination of truancy and
feigned illnesses.
He missed class a lot of the time.
When he was seven years old,
David was hit by a car and he suffered head injuries.
It's unclear whether this resulted in any longterm effects.
Soon after though he started to show signs of a fascination with fire.
He began burning bugs and advanced up starting fires around his neighborhood.
This didn't bring him to the attention of the authorities,
though his adoptive parents did take him to see a psychotherapist when he was 14
David's life was turned upside down with the death of his adoptive mother.
Paula had been fighting breast cancer for two years.
Paul was the only person with him.
David had a close relationship and he was shocked to watch her decline as she
went through chemotherapy treatments,
her death,
it was a crushing blow and the year after his mother's death,
David became increasingly introverted.
His schoolwork suffer drastically as he fell into a dock.
Depression.
He had no relationship with his father and things worse,
and when Joseph remarried,
his new step mother was even more distant than his father.
When the family relocated to Boynton beach near Miami,
Florida,
David's on isolation.
It became complete with no friends and no family connection.
He created a fantasy world in order to cope with his loneliness.
In 1971 that the age of 18 David found a means to escape is dismal life with his
father and stepmother.
He joined the army and is off to basic training.
He was sent to Korea all me life.
It was transformative for the troubled young men.
He seemed to respond well to the discipline that it provided and generally
equipped him well.
He trained as a marksman and became a good shot.
In 1974 he was honorably discharged after leaving the army,
David returns New York.
Here.
He was competing on his own.
He used money to save during a Zombie is to rents and apartments in the Bronx
and took classes at Bronx community college.
People remember him at this time,
isn't angry and argumentative,
young man who shun dissociation with others to support himself.
He worked a number of odd jobs including mail sorters,
security guard and cab driver.
Though very quiet Berkowitz quickly came to the attention of his neighbors and
the local police departments.
He would instigate petty disputes and escalate them with personal threats.
A man who lived on the floor below deputy police.
Sheriff Charles Glassman received 400 and threats from Berkowitz in his early
twenties.
Berkowitz connected with this Beth mouth up.
Hey began regular visits with Betty and his half sister Rosalyn.
However,
when he finds out that Betsy had given him up for adoption after succumbing to
pressure from his Beth father,
he did not react very well.
In fact,
he cut the two women out of his life completely,
never visited again.
Then in 1974 Berkowitz's fascination with fire resurfaced over the next three
years,
he sat more than 1,500 files around New York City.
David diligently recorded the details of each Austin and his journal referring
to himself as the phantom of the Bronx fire lighting gave him some control over
a situation that he couldn't find anywhere else in his life.
In 1975 Berkowitz develops another fascination and this time it was with the
occult.
After reading the Satanic Bible by ons and Lovey the founder of the Church of
Satan,
he became convinced that he was being controlled by evil spirits.
In late November,
1975 Berkowitz wrote a letter to his father in it.
He says it's cold and gloomy here in New York,
but that's okay because the weather fits my mood.
Gloomy Dad,
the world is getting dark now.
An unfun laser.
On Christmas Eve,
he took hold of a hunting knife and headed down to to satisfy his blood lust.
His first victim was a woman coming out of a grocery store.
Berkowitz stabbed several times before she managed to run away.
He then came across a 15 year old by the name of Michelle Foreman.
She was stabbed six times,
but for telephone attack.
That runs,
made it to the safety of a nearby apartment.
At the end of January,
1976 Berkowitz relocated from the Bronx to a rental house in Yonkers,
has landlords and a German shepherd dog,
which barked incessantly.
Berkowitz would lay to claim that this dog was possessed by Satan and it's
barking,
was commands for him to kill women.
At the time he was working a night shift job as a security guard.
He recalled that the constant barking almost caused him to take his own life.
After three months.
That noise was too much for backer since he moved to an apartment at 35 pine
street at Yonkers.
As it turns out,
he was unable to avoid the barking of dogs and he took this as a sign that Satan
was driving him to murder.
He used a Molotov cocktail to kill the dog belonging to his neighbor,
a man named Sam car.
When this didn't work,
he shot the dog.
Berkowitz was convinced that Sam car was possessed by the Devil Lens.
It was from him that he came up with a name,
son of Sam.
His two botched knife attacks,
convinced buck widths that he needed a more effective means of killing.
By June of 1976 he had built out a formidable arsenal of firearms that included
a 44 caliber revolver.
I commando mark three rifle at Glenfield rifle with a telescopic sight charter,
arms,
ar seven explorer shotgun and a 12 gauge ethica ds slash shotgun.
Towards the end of June,
1976 Berkovitz quit his job as a security guard and began driving for the co op
city taxi company,
but their job,
it didn't last long.
By the end of July,
he was working a day job as an installer of air conditioning ducts Berkowitz's
first kill and it came on July the 29th 1976 he left his apartment via the fire
escape.
Shortly before 1:00 AM with this 44 Canada handgun in a paper bag.
He hops into his car and began cruising for a victim.
He came across 18 year old Donna Lauria and said 19 year old friends,
Jody valency talking in a car outside Donna's apartment.
Berkowitz approached on a side window,
squatted down into a firing position,
holding the gun with both hands,
emptied the chamber.
Donna was shot and killed.
Jody was wounded and she reacted by screaming and desperately wrong in the car
horn.
Jody survived with his gun.
Empty Berkowitz melted into the night.
He was filled with the euphoria that he had never known before and his addiction
to murder was well underway.
The next attack.
It came at three months later on October the 23rd Berkowitz was again cruising
for a victim in the dead of the night.
He was driving down a street in flushing,
Queens when he spotted two people in a Red Ford Galaxy,
one of them had long black hair,
which he found attractive.
He began following them and when they came to a stop,
he parked behind them.
Burkowitz said,
set his sights on 20 year old called a narrow and his 18 year old date,
Rosemarie Keenan,
who happened to be the daughter of a New York City police officer.
Following the same pattern of his first murder,
Berkowitz approached the passenger window,
pulled out his handgun and fired five times.
One of the bullets smashed into calls,
had and uninjured.
Rosemary managed to escape the car and flee.
When backwards left,
she returned and drive call to the hospital.
Amazingly,
he survived with doctors having to insert a metal plate into a skull and month
later Berkowitz struck again.
This time his victims were a couple of teenage girls,
Joanne Amino and Donald and Marcy.
They were on their way home from the movies.
Buckowitz walked behind them and as they stood on the stoop of Joanne's house
talking,
he opened up with his handgun.
Then he disappeared.
Bullets tore through the bodies of both girls,
but neither was killed.
Although Joanne was paralyzed from the waist down the attacks,
they continued on January the 30th 1977 Berkowitz shot and killed Kristine.
He was just seeing the movie rocky with our boyfriends as with most of the
previous attacks,
the couple of web sitting in that car when Berkowitz I've been fired.
Then on March the eighth he killed a 20 year olds,
Bulgarian immigrants by the name of the Jenya Vauxhall Rakeon.
Virginia was walking home from Columbia University when she came face to face
with Berkowitz,
a shot her in the face at point blank range and then left her to die on the
sidewalk.
Then on April the 17th he attacks Valentina Syriani and Alexander or so as they
sat in their car at 3:00 AM Syriani died at the scene.
While isyeah died.
Hours later,
police came to the scene and they found a letter that had been left by the
killer.
It read in part,
I'm a monster.
I am the son of Sam.
I feel like an outsider.
I am on a different wavelength than everybody else.
Programs to kill.
However,
just stop me.
You must kill me.
I am the monster Beelzebub the Chubby BMF.
I love to hunt,
prowling the streets,
looking for fat game,
tasty meat that women of Queens or prettiest of all
my now the entire city of New York was in an uproar fair ever.
The next attack by the son of Sam led to a rush on handgun sales and a dramatic
emptying of nighttime entertainment venues.
The information that the majority of victims had,
long,
dark hair led to an overnight hairstyle,
changes.
Women rushed to get their haircut and then died.
The media was all over the story with coverage going global,
but still the attacks continued with Schilling regularity.
Berkowitz.
The next struck on June the 26th 1977 Judy placido,
age 17 and Sal Lupo age 20 we're setting a new postcard around 3:00 AM when
Berkowitz attacked in his usual way.
Placido was shot three times while Lupo was shot.
Once both survived amongst the lazy or tags or Bobby Vr Lanza and Stacy
Moskowitz both age 20 again Berkowitz fine through the passenger car window,
striking both of his victims in the head of the island's Ayp survived the,
he lost 90% of his vision,
but Stacy Moskovitz died two days later.
She marked the last victim of the son of Sam on March 30th,
1977 media hysteria was ratcheted it up even further when New York's most
prominent crime writer,
New York Times columnist and Jimmy Breslin and received a handwritten letter
from a person claiming to be the son of Sam.
It's included the following,
Mr Breslin,
sir,
don't think that because you haven't heard from me for awhile that I went to
sleep.
No.
Rather,
I am still here like a spirit.
Remming the night thirsty,
hungry.
Seldom stopping to rest.
Anxious to please Sam.
I love my work.
Now.
The void has been filled.
Perhaps we shall meet face to face someday or perhaps they will be blown away by
cops.
With smoking 30 eights Breslin contacted the police.
He noted that the letter contained the details of some of the crimes that have
not yet been released to the public.
They allowed the times to publish part of the latter as a companion to Breslin's
printed response,
which urged the killer to turn himself in that addition of the times,
so more than a million copies,
the NYP formed operation Omega the most comprehensive investigation in its
history.
In order to bring the son of Sam to justice,
over 300 detectives worked around the clock as a daily cost of $90,000 45
psychiatrists poured over the taunting letters that Burke of its was writing
with the general consensus being that he was a paranoid loner who was unable to
form relationships and with possible connections to devil worship on the nihs of
the Moscow woods,
Vln z shooting.
A woman named Cecilia Davis was walking her dog when she saw a police officer at
ticketing a young man in a car that was parked alongside of fire hydrants.
Soon thereafter,
she saw what appeared to be the same young man walked pasta as staring at a
menacingly.
It was enough to scare her into at speedy dash home.
After the murders,
Ms. Davis gave the information to the police.
As a result of this,
every driver who had been ticketed that night was brought in for questioning and
one of the people on that list was David Berkowitz,
a detective trying to get hold of backwards over the phone,
but there was no answer that just active then contacted the Yonkers police
station to see if they could help get them in touch with Berkowitz,
the dispatcher,
he spoke to you.
It just happens to be the daughter of Sam car,
David's former landlord,
and the inspiration for the son of Sam label that Burkowitz said,
anointed himself with the detective,
interviewed Sam Call who informed him that Berkowitz had shot his dog and was a
pretty troubled individual.
The physical and psychological description that was given to seems to gel rather
well with the profile of the son of Sam.
From this point on,
evidence against Berkowitz quickly mounted.
A suspected arson was reported close to his apartment,
but he's interviewed David's former neighbor,
Charles Gossman.
He showed them the nasty letters that Berkowitz had written to him.
On August the 10th 1977 detectives found his Ford Galaxy parked outside his
apartment,
although they didn't have a search warrant,
they began searching the car on the back seat was a duffle bag containing a
rifle.
Inside the glove compartment was a handwritten letter addressed to the Suffolk
County police department that warned of a coming attack on a disco.
One of the officers were sent to get a search warrant.
12 the officers stayed by the car and member of the public was stolen to park
his car,
so it was to box in the four to making it hard for back of heads to get away.
If he came out of his apartment,
a swat team was deployed around the area.
Finally at around 10:30 PM Berkowitz came out of his apartment and got into his
car and detective approached and tapped on his window the sun there.
Sam then rolled down the window and said,
well,
you got me.
How come it took you such a long time?
The arrest of the son of Sam caused a worldwide sensation.
It turns out that the monster who would terrorize the world's most famous city
was a rather pathetic looking loser.
Berkowitz admitted to all of the attacks providing details that only the
perpetrator would know.
On August the 11th he was charged with second degree murder for the killing of
Stacey Moskovitz.
The judge ordered a psychological evaluation to determine if he was fit to stand
trial.
Meanwhile,
the media was in a frenzy to cover every angle of the son of Sam Story.
This result is and the state of New York and acting what became known as the son
of Sam laws permitting the state to confiscate the proceeds from any earnings
made as proceeds of a crime for a period of five years after the act was
committed.
This money then goes to the victims of the crime.
As it turns out,
that was to be no trial.
Balco widths pled guilty to six counts of merger and refuse the edging of his
attorney to claim a defense of insanity.
He later status.
I just wanted to end it and I was so distraught.
I just confessed that guilty and got it over with and just wanted to get out of
that environment during a sentencing,
the mother of Stacy Moskowitz stood up and said,
I could kill him with my bare hands and I am not a violent person.
I could probably kill him and go for dinner and go to sleep that night.
Trudy peacefully during Mrs Moskowitz's statements,
Berkowitz repeated over and over that Stacy as a whole.
Then he burst from his seat and made for the courtroom window.
He was eventually restraints but not before knocking down several offices.
Sentencing was delayed until June the 12th 1978 on which date he was sentenced
to six consecutive life sentences.
Balco.
It's proved to be a problem prisoner.
He reveled in tormenting other inmates because of his rage and other inmates
referred to him as [inaudible].
On July the 10th,
1979 he was attacked by another inmate with a razor,
the resulting neck injuries that required 57 stitches.
After 10 years of confinement,
Berkowitz became a born again Christian.
There's angry mass kilo was converted into an evangelical passivist.
He absorbed himself in a letter writing campaign to spread the message of the
Bible.
Over the years,
uh,
following developed around Berkowitz is the ultimate example of the changed man.
The Modern Day equivalent of the Apostle Paul Berkowitz fest became eligible for
parole in 2002,
however,
he sends a letter to the parole board requesting that the hearing be canceled.
And as he stated,
in all honesty,
I believe that I deserve to be in prison for the rest of my life.
I have with God's help long ago come to terms with my situation and I have
accepted my punishment.
He has been up for parole every two years since 2002 but he has consistently
refused the opportunity to see cause freedom as a result.
He remains in prison to this very day where he is considered to be a model
prisoner.
Sorry,
have you found the video?
Interesting.
If he did,
did give us a thumbs up below.
Let us know what you think.
If you've got a suggestion for us as well,
leave that below.
And if you see when you lie,
give it that thumbs up and it'll rise to the top and then we're more likely to
see it and make it so do that.
If you fancy,
like I say,
subscribe like all of that good stuff and I'll see you in the next video.